all right happy memorial day everybody
we're uh
i thought i'd have the day off but they
have me here at daily wire studios
cooking meat for everybody for good
ranchers i'm now a cook i guess
[Music]
by the way before we get into the video
today
making good ranchers burgers and the
good ranchers burgers are so good that
uh even i can't screw them up which i
guess is why they're trusting me with it
go to goodranchers.com
wall shoes code walsh and get your own
good ranchers box they got burgers they
got snakes they got chicken all of it
again so good that even i can make it
you know something we like to do on the
matt well show in these videos is we
like to go to tiktok to the lost souls
of tick-tock
and uh kind of give them some advice and
the thing about on tick-tock is
they often have um these dating experts
who will give dating advice and so while
we're making some meat today i think
we're to go watch some of these dating
advice videos and i guess while i'm
making meat i'll just give some kind of
fatherly
responses to these dating advice videos
so let's uh let's go to the first one a
lot of times in data you're gonna
experience people that are hot and cold
right one week they're texting you like
crazy the next week they're being short
with you and they're not giving you so
much attention what's our first
emotional response to that it's call
them out right say hey listen i don't
understand why you're not hitting me up
or hey listen i think i need to take a
step back from this situation because
it's really bothering me let me tell you
something the worst thing that you can
do
is verbally tell someone that their lack
of attention dude grilling hot tubs even
if it's hippie houseboats telling them
gives them all the power the reality is
even if you're feeling that way you need
to take actions and stay silent you
can't say [ __ ] to them just take a step
back with actions don't say your moves
to somebody because let's say they don't
even they're not giving you attention
because they're actually busy then it
shows you're patient right and that's
better for you and then let's say they
actually don't give a they're got not
giving you attention that way their true
colors are going to come out at some
point so you're better off keeping your
mouth shut
and now what he says there is a
basically
if you think there's an issue
don't talk about it just remain silent
and hope that it works itself out and
the thing is as a man i can i can sort
of understand that instinctively
like i do apply that sometimes to
relationships when i shouldn't i apply
it to uh like household repair issues
something's broken my wife says can you
fix it i said just leave it it'll it'll
work itself out
medical problems
you know i feel a certain pain i just
say well just i'll leave it alone
but in reality that's not actually what
you should do okay
in a relationship you just talk to
somebody
and if you think there's an issue then
you have the conversation but here's the
other point
if you're just dating someone
and they're already flighty and they're
hot and cold and they're ignoring you
for a week and then they they're into
you for a week just break up
that's the easiest thing you could do
it's not worth your time if they're
already doing that
just break up
take my advice okay let's watch the next
one 15 really personal questions you
should consider asking on a first date
if you don't want to waste your time do
you want kids
do you want to be in a monogamous
relationship
do you want to get married one day who
did you vote for in the last election
who do you first go to for support how
often do you drink or do drugs how done
are you with your ex how important is
religion to you what's your main
priority in life how often do you want
to do it how adventurous are you in bed
when an argument happens do you
initially want to process it or get some
space would you ever be open to
relationship therapy what's your number
one deal breaker why do relationships
typically end for you
okay you see there
the first like five questions actually
weren't too bad
the problem is first of all is i can
pretty much guarantee that he's looking
for all the wrong answers to those
questions like like there are right
answers to those questions and that guy
specifically is probably looking for the
wrong answers the rest of it though
listen it's the first date
you do want to be careful that your
first date doesn't become like a law and
order
interrogation scene where you're going
through 20 questions how long are you
with your ex what are your priorities in
life like you want to be a little bit
careful with that and asking somebody on
a first date if they be open to
relationship counseling
i just met you this is crazy five
seconds ago and you're asking me if i'm
ready to be in counseling with you
that's that's a million red flags all at
once so
that advice at least unlike some of the
other stuff we've seen it started strong
went off the rails unfortunately
let's check out the next one
here are five easy ways to tell if he's
physically attracted to you number one
when you get close to him you notice his
nostril flare this isn't a coincidence
it's actually because he's sniffing you
for something called pheromones
pheromones are the chemical that
determine compatibility like if you guys
would make healthy babies together so if
you notice simpler's nostrils he's just
subconsciously sniffing you second sign
he's super physically attracted to you
is that when you look at his eyes his
pupils dilate this is because as humans
we tend to fixate and hone in on the
things that we like and the things that
we're after three is that you notice
he's sweating it is really common to
have like an elevated nervous system
around people that we like because we're
nervous and excited so if you notice him
sweating there's a good chance he's
attracted to you i wet my arm pants have
you ever been talking to a guy and
noticed that he's playing with or
touching his hair like a lot guys
involuntarily do this when they're
attracted to someone because mussed up
hair is more flattering so you're going
to notice them playing with their hair
quite a bit finally do you notice him
touching his face a lot when he's
talking to you when we're turned on our
faces and our mouth and lips are more
sensitive to touch hence kissing if he's
super attracted to you you may notice
him doing things that are an excuse to
touch his mouth more like taking more
sips of his drink
okay what have i told you about body
language science okay that's a that's a
science a fake science you put it in the
same realm as like astrology
climate change
okay um no you cannot read every little
movement that a person makes and and
then draw these wild conclusions
like
if they're sweating
then they're attracted to you i
i'm sweating right now who am i
attracted to the cameraman like who's
how does that make any sense i sweat a
lot i have over active sweat glands okay
it's a medical condition doesn't mean
i'm attracted to everybody in the room
that's the first thing
second thing is also
if you're a woman
like maybe if you're a man trying to
discern if a woman is physically
attracts you
that gets a little bit more complicated
if you're a woman and you want to know
if a man's attracted to you and you're
on a date with him i'll tell you how you
know
he is attracted to you because you're on
a date with him and if he was not
attracted to you physically he wouldn't
be there i think he likes you so that's
it that's all you need to know don't
have to watch for his eyes dilating or
how he moves his fingers or whether he's
sweating all right let's check out the
next one
so for all my girlies dating men this is
what you're going to do on your date
because i know dating can be awkward
okay but i learned this on tick tock and
i need to teach it to everyone okay so
the bell comes i'm you okay
do you need any help with that
okay that
what are they gonna say yeah you need
help with that on the bill that you
wanted to take me out to that i had to
get ready for i don't think so in a
patriarchy created by men where men are
paid more than women even though women
typically do a better job in a world
where all wars have been started by men
in a society where 90 of rapes are by
men don't even get me started on the
orgasm gap no babe when your gender
figures it out maybe we'll talk about it
all right
just out in the parking lot by myself
making burgers
watching tick tock videos totally normal
way to spend your memorial day now as
far as that video goes uh no this is you
can't have it both ways okay
i know this is what feminists they're
trying to do this they realize that they
back themselves into a corner with all
the empowered women stuff i'm an
independent woman well that means now
you got to pay the bill they don't want
to pay the bill so they're trying to
figure out a way to make it work where
they can still be an empowered
independent woman but also
expect the man to pay for everything and
it's just it's not going to fly and by
the way
she says that uh well men they you know
they do all the bad things in society
yeah men also uh i don't know build
society like every bridge you've ever
driven across it's because a man built
it every building you've ever been in a
man built it okay it's all men doing
that and here's the thing
we do all that we make the hamburgers we
build society
we're willing to do it
and we're also willing to pay the bill
but then you have to do your part of it
which is to drop the whole feminist and
powered stick
okay so we can it can work but you got
to play your role in this here's the
point
but that's also good because men if
you're watching this and you see women's
it's a very positive development i think
for women
to be on social media
saying things like this
because they're advertising themselves
and man you see that woman and you know
okay avoid that woman like the plague
or anybody like her
i think i could stomach maybe one more
of these videos so let's uh let's watch
one more
i gotta pull over for this
guys please enough of this the friend
zone is so easy to avoid because what is
important is what not to do not what to
do in order to avoid the friend zone you
have to be aware of the things that get
you friend zoned and not do those things
like asking her how her day was your
entire day and life should be aligned
with your purpose and what you are going
after in life if you are wasting your
time texting a girl throughout the day
to a point of where you can have a
conversation of how her day is going
you're doing something wrong texting
snapping phone call face time any kind
of constant communication throughout the
day will get you friend zoned always
being available always doing her favors
will get you friend-zoned always saying
yes to her will get you friend-zoned but
when you use my friendzone escape plan
the love story is just beginning
okay this is why i tell you guys
check the resumes especially important
for men if you got a man
who's on social media given all kinds of
advice about how to be a man
i want to know his resume like what do
you know about being a man
have you ever even made meat at a
barbecue are you married do you have
kids like i need to know all these
things before i'm gonna take advice from
you about how to be a man and i'm
guessing in this case he doesn't have a
lot of experience with it because all
the things he said
you shouldn't do
for a woman
those are all the things that if you're
married and you don't do those things
you're not going to be very married for
very long okay if you're with a woman
who will be turned off
because you asked her how her day was
she'll be turned off because you're
talking to her and showing interest
then that's just a good indication to
leave and go find
another woman just break up
take my advice and find a different man
to take advice from
like me um and also find somewhere else
to get your meats like good ranchers i
might have overcooked this one slightly
but that's okay go to goodranchers.com
walsh use codewalsh and have yourself a
great memorial day god bless america
godspeed
[Music]